this is what the Kremlin says was an
attempt on the life of Vladimir Putin
an object is intercepted by air defenses
Russia says it was a drone one of two
that officials say were launched by
Ukraine in an audacious attack aimed at
the Kremlin complex
two unmanned aerial Vehicles were aimed
at the Kremlin and official statement
reads as a result of timely actions
taken by the military and special
services with the use of radar Warfare
systems the devices were put out of
action
we regard these actions as a planned
terrorist act and an attempt on the
president's life
President Putin is not thought to have
been in the Kremlin at the time the
thinking appears to be that it was a dry
run in the footage in front of the
Kremlin walls it's evident that
preparations are underway for Victory
Day Celebrations on May the 9th an event
that Putin plans to attend
that May 9th at 10 o'clock in the
morning which it has to be in the red
square at the stand to observe the
Victory Day parade and that's at the
time of the day and year uh 9th of May
10 o'clock we have Putin's itinerary is
well known way in advance he should be
there so and it's a grandma said that
this wedge drone attack was a dry run a
preparation for May the 9th when Putin
will be vulnerably because his
whereabouts are known in advance
it is a theory that not everyone is
convinced about I've seen the reports
um I can't uh in any way validate them
we simply we simply don't know
um second I would take anything coming
out of the Kremlin with a very large
Shaker of salt
so let's see
on a visit to Finland president zelenski
denied Ukraine's involvement
we don't attack
Putin or Moscow
are we fight on on our territory we are
defending our Villages and cities we
don't have
you know enough weapon for this
[Music]
[Applause]
yet even as air raid sirens sounded in
the Ukrainian Capital the mere
possibility that Ukraine had struck a
blow at the heart of Russian power was
thrilling for some
my classmates and I have been talking
about this all day it's very cool I'm
very joyful it's lifted my spirits
in its official statement the Kremlin
said it reserves the right to take
retaliatory measures where and when it
sees fit Jonah Hall Al Jazeera